rising from the muck of the bayou and
into injustice to come Swamp Thing this
methodical grappler uses power gifted to
him by the green to create vines and
branches that aid him in his battle
against any foe that disturb him or his
verdant home Swamp Thing is a lumbering
behemoth with extraordinary range and a
multitude of grabs that can catch his
opponent at any distance while he may
not have much of an advantage against
speeding projectile users when he slows
down the pace of the match Swamp Thing
can sink any opposed let's not get too
bogged down in the description it's time
to get our feet wet with this Swamp
Thing gameplay overview with killing
field he creates a wooden Club and
repeatedly batches his opponents head
popping them up for follow-up damage
with Trump punch more swamp things arm
into a tree and hit your opponent
multiple times knocking them back two is
better than one with his combo family
tree team up with his clone to rush down
your opponent for a brutal mix-up what
Swamp Thing has established his
dominance with devastating combos the
opponent is left open for powerful grabs
and special moves use vine grab to grab
your opponent from virtually any range
and even out of the air showing your
opponent that nowhere is safe green
thumb is an overwhelming up-close grab
that gives swampthing multiple ways to
crush his opponents or even heal himself
along with his grapples you can also
branch out into full street offense with
log kick a low hitting projectile that
quickly slides across the ground finally
if you were struggling against your
adversaries projectiles his bio fission
creates a clone that grabs an opponent
allowing him to close the gap and deal
damage Swamp things character power
abigail's garden creates a patch of
flowers as a tribute to his beloved when
your opponent is in the garden their
mobility is limited and they are unable
to dash or jump making it easier to set
up devastating grabs finally put your
opponent in the ground with his super
move Green Kingdom
look for swampthing in a full roster of
DC heroes and villains in injustice to
coming May sixteenth 2017